>> Bret: A FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR FROM CHICAGO IS
NOW IN CHARGE OF TURNING
OVER SUBPOENAED JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT DOCUMENTS TO
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES
INVESTIGATING ALLEGED BIAS
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT IS THE LATEST MOVE IN
WHAT HAS BEEN A HIGHLY
CONTENTIOUS PROCESS.
TONIGHT, WE WELCOME THE U.S.
ATTORNEY IN CHARGE OF THIS,
JOHN LAUSCH.
THANK FOR BEING HERE.
>> HAPPY TO BE HERE, THANK
YOU.
>> Bret: LET'S START BY
ASKING YOU WHERE ARE WE NOW?
HOW MANY OF THESE DOCUMENTS
HAVE BEEN TURNED OVER.
>> THERE IS A HANDFUL OF
DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
TURNED OVER THERE ARE
I THINK THE KEY AT THIS
POINT IS REALLY IDENTIFYING,
YOU KNOW, WHAT ADDITIONAL
RELEVANT INFORMATION IS OUT
THERE, TURNING IT OVER AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
AND DOING SO IS COMPLETELY
AS WE CAN, GIVEN THE LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS THAT EXIST.
THERE ARE CERTAIN LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE AS
PROSECUTORS, WHICH PREVENT
US PROVIDING SOME DOCUMENTS,
LIKE GRAND JURY MATERIAL,
THINGS LIKE THAT.
BUT THAT'S REALLY WHERE WE
ARE AT IN THE PROCESS.
>> Bret: WHAT IS THE TOTAL
SCOPE OF WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT?
HOW MANY TOTAL DOCUMENTS?
>> OKAY.
SO AND THERE HAS BEEN SOME
MISNORM ABOUT THE DOCUMENTS
THAT ARE OUT THERE.
ONE OF THE NUMBERS THAT'S
OUT THERE IS 1.2 MILLION.
AND THAT'S THE ENTIRE
UNIVERSE OF MATERIALS THAT
WENT TO THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
THE NUMBER OF RELEVANT
DOCUMENTS IS GOING TO BE
MUCH LESS THAN THAT HOW MUCH
LESS THAN THAT?
I DON'T KNOW.
I ANTICIPATE A LOT LESS THAN
THAT, FOR VARIOUS REASONS.
ONE OF MY JOBS IS TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT ARE THOSE RELEVANT
DOCUMENTS TO WORK WITH THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE REVIEWING
THEM NOW AND TONE SURE THAT
WE GET THEM PRODUCED AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
>> Bret: CHAIRMAN GOODLATTE
BASICALLY ASKED FOR
EVERYTHING THE IKEGWUONU WAS --I
EVERYTHING THE IKEGWUONU WAS --G
EVERYTHING THE IKEGWUONU WAS --W
EVERYTHING THE IKEGWUONU WAS --S
EVERYTHING THE IKEGWUONU WAS --G
EVERYTHING THE IKEGWUONU WAS --V
EVERYTHING THE IKEGWUONU WAS --N
TO THE FBI.
>> RELATES TO THE CLINTON
MATTER.
>> Bret: OUR PRODUCER TELLS
ME THAT SOURCES FAMILIAR
WITH THIS PROCESS SAY IF YOU
LOOK AT THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION, THE NUMBER
GOES DOWN FROM 1.2 MILLION
TO ABOUT 400,000; IS THAT
RIGHT.
>> IT GOES DOWN A LOT LESS.
I'M NOT PREPARED TO SAY WHAT
THAT NUMBER IS YET.
I'M JUST GETTING STARTED.
I THINK IT GOES DOWN
SUBSTANTIALLY.
>> Bret: IF YOU DO BASIC
WORD SEARCHES, IT GOES DOWN
EVEN MORE?
>> AND THAT'S THE HOPE.
FIGURE OUT THE WAY TO
IDENTIFY THE MOST RELEVANT
MATERIALS AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN SO YOU GIVE CONGRESS
WHAT IT'S ENTITLED TO SO
THEY CAN DO THEIR JOB.
>> Bret: FBI DIRECTOR HE IS
SAID I'M DOUBLING THE STAFF
TO COVER 8:00 A.M. TO
MIDNIGHT TO EXPEDITE
COMPLETION OF THIS PROJECT.
IT IS APRIL 10TH, 15 DAYS
LATER.
YOU HAVE CAPITOL HILL UP IN
ARMS THAT THEY CAN'T GET
THESE DOCUMENTS.
THERE IS FRUSTRATION UP
THERE.
THERE IS FRUSTRATION FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
WHAT IS TAKING SO LONG?
>> RIGHT.
SO, I MEAN, BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE BOTH AS A
PROSECUTOR AND THEN A
PRIVATE PRACTICE BEFOREHAND,
DOCUMENT REVIEW, THEY CAN
JUST TAKE TIME.
ONE OF THE REASONS THEY TAKE
SOME TIME IS, YOU KNOW,
REVIEWING ALL THE TEEFERLS
TO LOOK FOR RELEVANCE.
BUT THEN TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
MATERIALS NEED TO BE
REDACTED OUT OF THERE.
AND SO THE ADDITIONAL FOLKS
THAT HAVE BEEN ADDED IS
GOING TO BE HELPFUL.
BRET BRIT I UNDERSTAND YOU
ARE JUST COMING ON.
YOU UNDERSTAND THIS PROCESS
HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A LONG
TIME.
>> RIGHT.
>> Bret: UP UNTIL YOU.
>> Bret: HERE IS TREY GOWDY
UP ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> IF THERE IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE, WE WANT IT
REDACTED.
BUT, MOST OF WHAT THEY SEND
US NOW LOOKS LIKE AN INK
BLOT TEST.
I WANT TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE FBI AND DOJ BUT THE
WORLD'S PREMIER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY CAN'T
SEEM TO OPERATE A DAMN
COPYING MACHINE.
WE ARE TIRED OF BEING
PATIENT.
>> Bret: YOU HEAR THAT
FRUSTRATION?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I'M HERE IS TO
ADDRESS THAT SPECIFIC
FRUSTRATION.
I LOOK FORWARD TO MEETING
THE CONGRESSMAN TOMORROW.
I HAVE MET SOME OTHER
CONGRESSMAN TODAY.
AND IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH
EXACTLY THAT ISSUE.
I THINK THE REDACTION ISSUE
IS AN ISSUE THAT WE JUST
NEED TO CONFRONT HEAD ON AND
ABOUT WHY CERTAIN THINGS ARE
WE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACTED AND FIND
A WAY TO GIVE THEM FAITH
THAT WHAT THEY ARE GETTING
IS THE RIGHT INFORMATION
EXPLAIN WHAT THAT IS AND WHY
THEY ARE NOT ENTITLED TO Z.
IT.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT'S
TWEET IS WHAT DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THE FBI HAVE TO HIDE.
DOCUMENTS UNREDACTED TO THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
STALL BUT FOR WHAT REASON
NOT LOOKING GOOD.
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE ON THIS ISSUE?
>> I HAVE NOT.
EARLIER TODAY.
I MET WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND THE FBI.
IT'S VERY CLEAR MY DIRECTION
IS TO GET THE DOMENTSZ
PRODUCED AS QUICKLY AS WE